[音楽]
こんにちはお願いします
改めまして皆さんはじめまして初めまして
私たちは荒れてるチャンネルという名前で
YouTube活動しています
[笑い]
YouTubeでは主にメイクや部屋事情
などの私たちと同じようなハーフの子たち
が
参考にできるようなコンテンツはもちろん
あるあるネタや木版などの誰でも楽しめる
ようなコンテンツも配信していますはい
先ほどの挨拶は私たちが毎回
YouTubeでしているオープニングの
挨拶になりますぜひ今日が終わったら皆
さんアリチルチャンネルで検索してみて
くださいよろしくお願いしますお願いし
ますはいじゃあ本題に入りまして私は日本
人の母とガーナ人の父を持つハーフです私
は日本人の母とナイジェリア人の父を持つ
ハーフです2人とも日本生まれ日本育ちで
エンジニアには行ったことがなく
父の国の言葉はもちろん英語も話せません
そんな見た目に反して中身は完全に日本人
の私たちですがこれまでハーフという
アイデンティティにより様々な経験をして
きました最近ではスポーツや芸能でも活躍
している方が多くハーフという存在は割と
身近になってきているかと思いますまた
どちらかというとハーフであることという
のはポジティブに捉えられていることが
多いのではないでしょうかしかし私たちに
とってハーフであることは地獄でした地獄
とは簡単に言えば言葉にしたくもないよう
な辛い経験のことを指します
今日これからさせていただくお話は私たち
の話ですが決して私たちだけの話ではあり
ませんなぜなら地獄というのは今聞いて
くださっている皆さん一人一人の中にも
存在しているからです地獄とも言い切れて
しまうような辛い経験を重ねた過去から
私たちがハーフというアイデンティティを
どのように受け取り見つめ直してきたのか
そして地獄とともにある特権制とは何だっ
たのか本日はそんな自分の中の地獄と特権
性についてお話しさせていただきます今日
のこの機会が皆さんが自分の内側にある
地獄と向き合いまた今日よりもちょっと
自分を好きになれるようなそんなきっかけ
になれば幸いです
じゃあ自分の中の地獄と特権性これを話し
ていくにあたってまずは私たちにとって
地獄の部分に当たる
過去の辛い体験から話していこうかなって
思います小学校から中学校ぐらいにかけて
私たちはどちらも普通になりたいっていう
漠然とした思いを持っていました普通って
何だという話にはなってきますがこの頃の
私たちにとっての普通とは
肌が黒くなくて髪の毛がサラサラなことを
指していました
当時の私たちは
布石でいわゆるアフロと呼ばれるぐらいの
ボリュームのあるヘアスタイルでした
毎日のように友達から
髪の毛トイプードルみたいで可愛いんだね
みたいな感じで髪の毛を触られていたん
ですけど周りの子と同じようなサラサラな
髪の毛に憧れていた私たちからすると全く
いい気はしませんでしたもちろんその友達
に悪意がないっていうこともわかってい
ましたし何よりトイプードルが
可愛いっていうことはもちろん
事実だと思うので分かっていたんですけど
私が思い出すのは小学校で下級生の知ら
ない男の子に
肌が黒いねと言われそれをたまたま見てい
た先生がそんなこと言っちゃダメと注意し
た場面です男の子のいた肌が黒いねという
のは子供の純粋な疑問であり単なる事実
です
先生は生徒を守ろうとする善意からこの世
に注意をしてくれたのだと思うんですけど
それは同時に先生自身が
肌が黒いイコール普通ではないという無
意識の固定観念そしてそこから生まれる無
意識の差別意識を持っていることを意味し
ていたと思います
私たちが持つ価値観だったり固定観念って
いうのは周りの環境から大きく影響を受け
て作られていくものです特に学校っていう
場はそれらの形成において非常に重要な
位置を占めますそこでの先生の相手発言は
私が自分が周りとは違うという事実を
否定的に受け取ってしまうきっかけになっ
たことはもちろんその注意を受けた男の子
の考え方にも曲がった影響を与えたのでは
ないでしょうか
そうですねその
頃そういった日常を過ごしていく中でその
頃の私たちはだんだんと自分のからに
閉じこもって誰も私のことなんか分かって
くれない
わかられてたまるかみたいな感じで周りに
壁を作ってそうですねそうやって自分を
守ってるようなそんな感覚がありました
そんな当時の私たちを変えたのが様々な
バックグラウンドを持つ生徒が集まり多様
性にあふれる都立国際高校など出会いと
その環境です私たちのように見た目に反し
て全く英語が話せないハーフをはじめ
準日本人にも関わらず人生の大半を海外で
過ごしてきた子や若干16歳にして5カ国
語を操る秀才など
想像をはるかに超えるほどのインパクト
抜群な同級生の姿がそこにはありました
そしてこのように育ってきた環境だったり
アイデンティティが異なるということは
それぞれがこれまで普通だと信じていた
価値観や感覚も異なるということを意味し
ますつまり国際高校には私たち2人がこれ
まで無意識のうちに押し付けられて自分を
何とかそこに当てはめようとしてもがいて
いたたった一つの普通ではなくたくさんの
普通が
存在していました
そしてこのように自分と異なる
文化だったり価値観が交差する国際高校の
環境下で私たちはもっと他の人のことを
知りたい関わりたいと思うようになりまし
たそしてこのような状況下では互いに対話
をしなければ始まりませんこのことはそれ
まで自分を悲劇のヒロインだと信じ込んで
いた私たちが他者の他者に耳を傾けると
同時に自分の内側と向き合い今まで
閉じこもっていた殻を壊さなければなら
ないと気づくきっかけになりました日本で
生まれ育ってきた私たちには最初このよう
な常に自己主張の飛び交う環境に少し違和
感がありましたがこうした環境が次第に
自分たちの中で凝り固まっていた何かを
溶かしていくのを感じていました
国際高校での体験を経て世界は自分が想像
しているよりももっと外側に広がってい
るっていう事に気がついた私たちは高校を
卒業して自己意識の矢印の向きもどんどん
外へと変わっていきました今まで感じてい
た疎外感を自分の中で抱えきれるように
なった私たちはお互いに言わなくても
わかるある共通した思いを持つようになっ
ていましたそれは自分と同じようなハーフ
の子の力になりたいっていう思いです
日本でハーフとして生きる私たちが
ぶつかる壁の一つにメイクやファッション
があります今時そういうメイクのメイクや
ファッションの知識を得ようと思ったら
YouTube動画美容系の
YouTube動画を見たりファッション
誌を読んだりインフルエンサーが発信する
コンテンツを見るなど様々な方法があると
思いますがどのYouTube動画を見て
もどんな雑誌を読んでもどんなテレビ番組
を見ても私たちが自分も参考にできるかも
しれないと思えるようなコンテンツは
なかなか見つかりませんでしたまた
昔から会得していたファッション誌では
私たちと同じような黒人ハーフの
専属モデルが起用されているのを見たこと
がありません
このように
肌の色をはじめとして
髪質や体型といった部分において
完全には参考にすることができない
コンテンツにばかり触れているうちに
いかに自分がこの社会で想定されていない
人間なのかっていうことを実感するように
なりました私たちと同じように感じている
人は絶対他にもいるっていう強い確信を
持ったのと同時にどうしたらそんな人たち
の力になれるのかそれを考えた時に私たち
のもう一つの共通点だったメイクや
ファッションへの関心を活かすということ
を思いつきましたそして大学1年生の冬
YouTubeやろうよという私の一言
からなんとなく集まって
森と勢いでYouTuberになりました
そのなんとなくの気持ちはノリと海苔と
勢いの裏側に確かに熱い思いがあったこと
は2人とも感じていました
こうしてハーフの子の助けになりたい元気
づけたいという思いで始めた
YouTube活動だったんですけどその
初めてやっていく中で気づいたら発信して
いる私たち自身が
救われているということに気がつきました
コメントやメッセージを通して様々な声に
触れるたびに一人じゃないんだよって言っ
てもらえてるようで勇気が湧いたしもっと
発信したいという思いにもつながりました
さらにYouTube活動を続けていく中
で自分の中で地獄であったはずのハーフで
あるという事実が少しずつ解けていくのを
感じていました今までは地獄としてしか
捉えることのできなかったハーフである
ことが実は特権的な面でもあったという
ことに気づかされたのです
はい
すいませんここまでしてきた話は私決して
私たちの不幸自慢でもハーフへの差別偏見
をやめろと言った単純な訴えかけでもあり
ません自分の中の地獄と特権性
私たちにとってハーフであることは自国
そのものでした自分が自分であるという
ただそれだけでそこには抱えきれないほど
の
悲しみと疎外感が広がっていてそしてそれ
はこのまま終わることがないように感じ
られました
いえ実際に終わることはなかったんです
私たちの地獄は今もなお続いていますそれ
はなぜか私たちはずっと私たちのままだ
からです地獄とは私たちのように社会から
疎外感を感じる体験だったりトラウマだっ
たりコンプレックスだったりというような
何らかのきっかけから個人の中で発生し
広がっていくものです周りには見えなくて
も誰に誰しもの中に広がっているものだと
思いますだからこそ今ここにいる皆さんに
自分ごととして聞いて受け止めて考えて
ほしいなと思います
自分の中に地獄があることばかりに目を
向けるとかつての私たちのようにそこから
抜け出せなくなり自分が持っている特権性
も見えなくなってしまいますそしてそれは
本当の意味で自分のことを理解していると
は言えないのではないでしょうか
大切なのは自分が自分であることで他者
からそして社会から何を享受しているのか
つまり自分が持っている特権性をよく
思い起こすことだと思います
私たちはハーフですそれによっていろんな
絶望や困難も味わってきましたが私たちは
ハーフであるからこそこうして今ここに
立っていられると思います
また私たちが当たり前だと思っていること
は他の誰かにとっては当たり前じゃないか
もしれません特権生徒はそんな自分の中の
当たり前そのもののことを指すのだと思い
ます
人はどうしても手に入らないものや
失ったものばかりに意識が行きがちですだ
からこそ周りの人には地獄なんてなく特権
ばかりを持っているかのように思えて
しまいます自分の中にもそして他者の内側
にも地獄と特権性が共存しているという
ことを理解することそれをして初めて自分
っていうものの輪郭が
浮き上がり見えてくるのと同時に自分にも
他者にも優しく接することができるのでは
ないでしょうか
そして最後にもし今かつての私たちのよう
に現状に生きにくさを感じている人がい
たら世界は自分が思ってる以上にもっと
広いことそして自分の知らない世界は
もっと外側に広がっているということを
信じてほしいと思います
いつだって私たちは行こうと思えばどこへ
でも行きます今生きている世界だけを見て
悲しい気持ちになったり絶望してしまっ
たりした時はこのことを思い出してほしい
なと思います自分を理解することは他者を
理解すること他者を理解することは自分を
理解すること
一人一人が自分の中の地獄と特権性を
見つめ見つめたその先にいる自分も丸ごと
愛せたらと一人一人が互いの地獄を想像し
互いに愛と優しさを持って
接することができたらと
願うばかりです
本日はこのようにお話しさせてお話しする
機会を設けていただき本当にありがとう
ございましたそして何より何者でもない
私たちの話に耳を傾けてくださりとても
嬉しかったです
皆様のこれまでとこれからが
健やかで温かいものでありますようにと
本当に心からお祈りしていますありがとう
ございましたありがとうございました